all right would you rather only watch
anime for your entire life or only play
games for your entire lifeam yeah
games you don't even do that anyway
anymore Joey I I would rather play games
well you got this is this any hard thing
for you yeah I like anime a lot don't
can be wrong but games games easily also
you can spend more time on a single game
than you can on like an average anime
season you know so like you just get
more bang for your
buck what if okay Joey what if we
included manga in that oh like cuz cuz I
could go without anime if I had manga
but if I'm just cutting out anime and
manga that makes it really really
[__] hard for me that's true uh
because I do obviously like I watch a
lot of anime but I also enjoy playing my
games as well and if I didn't have to
watch anime for a job it I would rather
I think it would actually be a 50/50
about how much anime I watch versus how
much games I play yeah so yeah it's hard
cuzz I I probably read just as much
manga as I do play games yeah but it
says anime for this question so I'm
taking the games Joey taking the easy
way out taking the easy option also I've
already watched most anime so I don't
want to rewatch them yeah I think oh
this is hard because I I think if I had
to make the choice I do think I get more
emotionally attached to anime but I
think for like the amount of time
investment you put in
I got to go I can't like give up games
cuz you could also get the anime in the
game what you mean jrpgs no there's like
there's some games where you can like s
online game load videos or links in like
V
CH oh yeah you could watch anime in VR
chat comp play games and Anime well I I
mean I'm going to assume that that's
just like a legal loophole that Roy
clearly didn't think about that there
cut scenes you know yeah there's cut
scenes that that do me my other reason
is because just purely because as of
like my point in my life right now I
have played less games like in the
broader spectrum of the gaming world
than I have watched anime in the broader
spectrum of the anime world so there's
more excitement for me because there's
more Choice with gaming yeah it would
suck though if you made disagreement and
it's like every show you're halfway
through You' to stop watching you can't
finish you'd be like [__] I wouldn't
know how it ends that would suck and no
and and like for some reason no one else
can tell you like You' never find out
you never get to get that Joy of finding
out How It Ends true
maybe yeah maybe maybe that's a blessing
in disguise so because maybe I wouldn't
be [__] youy maybe I wouldn't be
spoiled on j- jit kaon for the hundredth
time when I'm scrolling through my [__]
I everything has been SP for me about
that show it kind of sucks it's it's
problem it's insane cuz I went like four
years I was like no Attack on Titan
spoilers and then suddenly I know the
entire plot of jiit kaon from now to
what's going on with the manga uh and I
get a different thing every single day
dude I could probably tell you just as
much about J Ka I haven't even [__]
watched the show I tell you the
character all death to
come know I can tell you how they die uh
I I can tell you everything I can write
the wiki
bro I'm also I I watched all of the
available episodes of freerun as of the
day of recording oh okay did you like it
it's [__] good really good very
[__] good not number one anime of all
time no solid
it is very very [__] good G yeah um
all right next one that's enough anime
talk this is the real question would you
rather spend a year in Ohio or a year in
Paris oh at least it would be Paris it's
at least a walkable City and I can get
nice coffee and also you're in Europe so
you it's a lot easier to access other
countries presumably you can't leave for
a year oh if you can't leave well I
imagine you'd have to spend the year
then oh oh I see I see uh yeah I'd say
Paris oh Ohio what can I do I can go to
McDonald's I can go to Wendy's I can go
to a Chick-fil-A in Paris I can go
sounds pretty good
actually okay well Paris I get a nice
coffee I can get some good baked quason
uh some other good stuff some good foods
do will I have to deal with an angry
French person every day probably but hey
I'll manage yeah I mean this is this is
Ohio we're talking about Ohio is so bad
Ohio is the final boss not as bad like
Montana well Montana's kind of all right
Montana's right yeah it's it's all right
it's Ohio it's it's Ohio yeah there'd be
very few places that could uh like
battle Ohio in the you know in the final
boss the It's the final boss uh so yeah
yeah we'd rather spend the year in Paris
I think I think Paris for all of us so
the maniton asks would you rather give
the first 90% of [__] of a [__] or
give the last 10%
asking three JoJo fans here that's uh
that's a really good one because oh man
cuz you have to now presumably you get
nut in your mouth yeah you have to
debate with yourself do you want nut in
your mouth or do you want to endure the
large majority but no nut in your mouth
yeah so it's it's all about the nuts
it's it's the nut question basically do
you want do you want to take the nut or
do you want to put in the effort suck a
dick and uh and I'll I'll do the last
10% you know I think I did the last time
I feel like I you know I'm the one who
did it I did the job I did it you know
it's all me all I got all the credit for
the work why not why not yeah also you
know depending on the dude it'll take
like two seconds or it could take like I
or if it's Johnny SS you'll be there for
40 minutes yeah you could be there for
40 minutes you give like [__] jaw
problems you know if it was me it'd be
like two seconds what a [__] dumbass
question stupid ass question well some
people don't want none their mouth M oh
my you know how it why is this a
question so
bad all right going on to the next one
let's
see uh go back to daily uploads or
stream every single day I mean streaming
every I I feel like this is the same
question but if it was if this was me
I'd rather stream every
day because I think daily uploads like
streaming is basically just doing daily
uploads just without the uh just without
the chat interaction basically also you
can make more content out of like a full
day of stream than you can of like a
full day of making daily uploads I feel
so yeah but you need to stream every day
so actually actually if you if you do
daily uploads you can get away with
doing one stream like seven ideas worth
and then you've got your daily uploads
right yeah or like having like one
having one recording session yeah where
you just oh [__] you're
right I think they they're kind of the
same thing really if you think about it
it's just whether or not you want to
stream or not yeah uh I I actually think
I I do daily uploads yeah I think daily
upload I I do daily uploads you you
could batch that's true could record A
month's worth that's true yeah all right
Mason lasagna asks would you rather be
only able to [__] in one minute Max or
have to [__] for at least 30 minutes so
no in between how the mechanics be of
this like like you're you're one minute
in and your pants like robotically just
back up I mean yeah you yeah probably I
you sho
yourself I think think you just
described the two different types of
[__] that are sitting on this table
you basically you basically described
are you a woman or are you a
man I don't know about you dude my
sister shits in like 30 seconds it's
actually insane I [__] in one minute I
[__] in 30 minutes yeah no no yeah I
thought that was more normal like taking
like 30 minutes for a dude no what I
what I do is is I get there I take the
[__] it takes like 30 seconds and then I
sit there for 10 minutes cuz I just want
to sit down really yeah what about
what aspect of this is taking 30 [__]
minutes the dud takes 30 minutes just
chilling out okay are you are you like a
toothpaste roll are you like you
crimping the
inside I've explained this before but
you know like when when you go take a
[__] right when you go take a [__] you
sit down and then it's just like that
immediate relief that you get like a
good like 70% hour and you could walk
away I know you're talking about you
could walk away you could walk away
psychotic what you mean it looks
psychotic well he only brings 100% of
the effort to the toilet this is why
you're going to get hemorrhoids before
the age 50 g cuz you're trying to
squeeze out the last 30 which isn't
coming out it's not ready yeah I thought
you said you'd let gravity do it work if
it was ready yeah that's cuz it takes 30
minutes it no but if you're straining
that's not gravity doing it work that's
you forcing it out no no no it's it's
like you get 70% out and then you could
feel there's a bit more there's a little
bit more I res I reserve that for my
afternoon [__] you just got to come back
later you if that's like pre-ordering my
he just keeps sitting it's just you
you'll get it out no you're forcing it
out that's why are you forcing it out
that's literally how you get HRS you're
going to get HRS CU you're [__]
forcing it out you know what let just I
you know fine I'm going to get
hemorrhoids then when when when I get my
100 B the moment you get the diagnosis
you got to give me a clean 100 you get a
double Bill one from corner one from the
I know the exact sensation you're
talking about because I've been on the
toilet where I've had the same feeling
and I'm like I think it will come out if
I sit here and just try and get it out
for 30 minutes and it's just it's better
just walk away just say no it doesn't I
can't just be completely empty I'm going
to come back when it wants to come out
look I don't really care what doctors
say this is like when doctors say oh oh
don't don't use that's a good I don't
care what doctors I don't care all
doctors it's like when doctors say oh
don't use cotton BS to clean your ears
we like we a lot of us are still going
to do it let's be honest guys I do I
listen to doctors huh I listen to the
doctors when it suits my agenda
exactly you know what if do say Do not
sit down for the rest of the 30% [__]
that you can tell is still in there
after you take a [__] I'm going to be
like but I'm going to do a game a move
anyway I'm I'm going to sit down my dad
we got to get a poop expert on the
podcast that's what we need and honestly
why would you want toist why would you
want to deprive yourself of like just a
nice relaxing [__] I don't understand
why in the middle of [__] recording
gone gone for I got [__] to do come on
we we we're waiting on you and you're
here like dangling it out go to get it
out
no no sometimes sometimes I just it's
just hard for me to focus so you don't
want to [__] in one minute you want to
take 30 minutes I think if I had to I'd
rather take 30 minutes that's [__]
that's preposterous I mean like I'm
think that's such a long time CU I'm
thinking about it now I'm thinking about
it now and it's like on average how long
do I take that make like a curse video
about your guys' lifespan that be like
you spend 50 million hours sleeping and
then 2% of your life [__] hey was actual
okay here's the thing would you would
you rather only be able to sleep for 1
hour or have to sleep 8 hours every
single day this taking into account that
you'll be fine even after 1 hour sleep
yeah why the [__] would I want to sleep
1 hour is as in like you're saying that
like I have the option like you'll be
fully rested even after an hour yeah you
can 100% yeah totally and I and I and I
don't get the normal 16 hour like tired
cycle so I would get would I what time
would I get tired would it be like 1
hour before I go to bed or would I get
tired like hours before let's say say
every night it happens between 1: and 2:
a.m. so so I'm sleeping between like 2:
and 3:00 a.m. but I get TI around 1 yeah
yeah dude but then by 5:00 a.m. you're
fully awake and fully rest are you
kidding me yeah [__] yeah hell yeah not
even a question the amount of the the
amount of time you have is insane
because think about it this way G right
like okay you say like you just added
25% of active time to your life cuz
think about it this way right like you
okay they like you sleep for 8 hours
right sure you get the full eight hours
but in your head it doesn't feel like 8
hours does it does it yes it does no it
doesn't yes it does because when you're
asleep you have no conception of time
because you're asleep yeah but okay when
you wake up you judge it by waking up
yeah you judge it by waking up but still
sometimes you know when you've just okay
sometimes you over sleep you know when
you over sleep right you you you to your
body tells you hey you just slept a [__]
time and you [__] and you know that
every time I don't know to me I I I look
at sleep the same way I look at [__]
you know is it always the most efficient
use of time no obviously if I could like
if if I could cut out all [__] in my
life I would give myself x amount of
more time in the day you know but do I
enjoy the fact that I can good look
forward to like a good nice rested sleep
um for like but you can get that within
an hour the hour gives you that same
sensation also let me let me propose
this G if you could if you only had to
sleep for an hour and you'd be fully
rested that's more time for you to take
a sh I'm literally just offering you
more time there's no down I'm just
saying hey you can just have straight up
more time in your life you're like no I
don't want
that yeah I mean okay I'd rather I'd
rather spend that extra time that I have
to be fully unconscious it's like I'm
saying do you want seven hours a day
extra to do [__] and you're like no do
we need seven hours a day to do extra
[__] God do we need do we
need we would be in flying cars if that
was happening right now be watching all
the [__] I that is on my back yeah I'd
actually be watching anime I feel like
that's a
lie Joey that's an
AB that's play games that is an absolute
lie yeah I don't know I mean more time
is great I
guess in in like The Logical sense would
I be happier with more time I don't know
I don't know if i' would be happy with
more time but I mean like sure but like
you would be able to I mean what you do
with that extra time is up to you right
I think so like I think just even having
that option is better off especially for
people in our position where we have to
be you know on our own time schedules
and be as productive as we can with the
limited amount of time we have think
about think of how much [__] we can make
if you just had an extra even 5 hours in
we just become even more Workaholics and
I don't know if that's a good thing or a
bad thing or you can spend that extra 7
hours watching anime playing games
whatever the [__] you yeah whatever the
[__] you want it doesn't matter you know
you can you can use that time however
much I feel like when you have an
abundance of something is when you stop
appreciating what you have you know
that's that like why aren you like that
with [__] then sorry why aren't you
like that with [__] I I do
appreciate that what are you talking
about Joey I appreciate the time I have
with [__] youly have an abundance over
there that's for sure you're saying that
23 hours a day is too much time for you
I I think it would be I don't know 23
hours a day that's a lot of time right
and yes I could be a more productive
member of society and all that kind of
[__] do I think I would be happier with
23 hours of time in the day I don't know
if I would be because I would I mean
right now I'm like every let's say like
you know all three of us every spare
moment we have we fill that [__] up with
uh just doing more work right we know we
we we say to ourselves hey we uh we
would like to watch more anime we would
like to play more games but you know
I've you've had like a holiday where you
have like a week off and then you just
do nothing but become a degenerate and
play games watch anime then you're like
[__] I feel like [__] cuz I didn't do
anything but play games and a watch
anime for S days straight and then
you're like yeah but that's because
you're playing it for seven days
straight like if you had that extra
seven hours in the day like you would
after a while once you actually got your
body and mind into that Rhythm you'd be
able to start you know uh like you know
putting you know a certain schedule
together of like okay yeah sure I have
that extra 7 hours but I can maybe split
it up with like maybe 3 hours of that is
working and then 4 hours of it is doing
whatever the [__] I want right I feel
yeah I mean we could do that anyway Joey
we like people do thatway more time
think of how many jrpgs you could finish
Joey here's the thing Joe you could
finish Final Fantasy in a day Joey
that's crazy here's the thing Joey I do
not believe for a second that if you had
more time that you do all the things
that you think you're going to do have
you ever had that moment where okay
you're in like you're you're you're in
exam like you're in exam period or
something right or you're in like a
period where you're in time in work sure
and then all you can think about is holy
[__] if I had more time I can't wait for
this project to end cuz once this
project ends then I'm going to have time
to do X Y and Z and all you can think
about is fantasizing about having this
project in or having exams end right and
then exams end and you have all the time
in the world and you're like the [__] do
I do what do I do now what do I what do
I do now speaking for yourself G after
exams I went hard you have like a day or
where you're like [__] this is great I
immediately was like I can't wait to
play 10 hours of games yeah yeah totally
I and then I played 10 hours of games
and then two like like two days in I was
like [__] I don't know what to do with
my time anymore this is I did not feel
that way I I think I played it for like
s months straight dud think think of the
amount of like new hobbies you can pick
up just even in that time like you could
do whatever the [__] you want in that
time yeah but with new hobbies you'd
have to like go with the Circadian
rhythm of the rest of the world anyway
you know you you AR
you don't have to not necessarily what
if your new hobby is like building gpla
you can do that at three you can do that
three in the [__] morning learn that
we live in a global world and there's
always day somewhere there's always
going to be someone to hang out with or
do stuff anytime you are awake someone
is awake on disc I also have
teleportation ability in this
universe it's really cool the only
downside to only getting only needing
one hour of sleep is that uh long flight
would be a [__]
chore you mean cuz you wouldn't be able
sleep through it cuz you'd only need an
hour and then if you're on a 12-hour
flight you'd just be awake for 11 hours
doing what watching
anime [__]
that that's what I do Joey I just like
to me flight's just like oh it's my uh
Mar Marathon be watching the same Jason
Stan movie five times in a row oh yes
the one and
to but yeah to me I feel like I
definitely like my rest time you know
and it's it's something I cherish and
it's something that I feel like I don't
know if I would want to get rid of even
if I had the opportunity to get rid of